the next Awards category is for  documentary pictures  perhaps we should introduce the  presenters in documentary style so they  are married he's Robert Wagner she is  Natalie Wood  the nominees for the feature documentary  award are Antarctic Crossing James Carr  the hidden world Robert Snyder  psychiatric nursing Nathan Zucker white  wilderness fence sharks team the winner  is white wilderness been sharp sting  tonight I have two pockets for well  thank you again  the nominees for the short subject  documentary award are amma girls been  sharps teen employees only kenneth g  brown journey into spring Ian Ferguson  the Livingstone Tom Daley overture Thor  old Dickinson and the winner is i'ma  girls been sharp stick  once again excepting for mr. Ben sharps  team mr. James Algar